hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the chess.com Global Chess
Championship Finals it is the second day
and it is with the white pieces against
Wesley so with black this is the second
game of the of the second part of the
match basically this is game six and if
you remember in the first four games
Wesley won both of his games with the
white pieces both of his game with the
draw pieces ended with a with the black
piece of sandal with a draw and uh now
nihal uh needs to beat Wesley in the
second part of the match which means
Wesley only needs one and a half points
out of the four games to actually uh win
the entire thing and win two hundred
thousand dollars which is uh absolutely
incredible and uh starting of the day
two nihal got a draw uh where Wesley had
the white pieces so at least he stopped
the bleed and this is now game six where
uh a lot of cool things happen so let's
check it out and see how this impacts
the the entire picture uh Sony with the
white pieces opens with D4 and it's very
interesting we're gonna have the same
opening that nihal used with white
absolutely annihilate Niche Geary in the
semi-final so let's see how Wesley deals
with that Knight to F6 C4 E6 and now
again this bishop to F4 like the ninth
most popular idea in this position uh we
have D5 by Wesley C captures Knight
captures attacking the bishop and Bishop
to G3 we have Fantasy 5 and pawn to E4
so everything the same as in the game
against Anish giri Knight to F6 with
Knight the D2 giving up the the D4 pawn
and now if you remember in the game
against the uh Anish Anish played C
captures and D4 also we mentioned that
Knight the C6 there is a game from the
US Championship where Ray Robson
defeated Hans Neiman would Knight to C6
but Wesley just goes for Queen captures
and D4 and it's sort of a okay the
engine says C captures on D4 and queen
capture Sandy for are all pretty much of
the same value maybe the engine prefers
Queen captures on D4 uh a bit more so
obviously Wesley knew about this as
nehal won a very nice game against Anish
so he prepared for it and it is now as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game so okay Knight G2 F3 uh nihal
very happily it develops the Knight
which Temple the queen is attacked Queen
back to d8 and now Pawn to E5 so similar
in the game against Anisha nihal wins
the D6 and F6 squares Knights the D5 and
now A3 not allowing B4 uh to be used for
the Knight if the knight ever comes to
B4 then you have to be careful Knight to
D3 could be an option so best to just uh
deny a black this option Bishop to A7
with Bishop to D3 uh the bishop here is
being x-rayed by the queen but there's
just no good Discovery to be be made
with the Knight so Bishop to D7
continuing development Queen E2 and now
Pawn to A6 we have Castles by both sides
castles castles and now Rook 8 to D1 and
even though there are four pieces in
front of this Rook uh but it's it still
could mean a lot if some of the pieces
move like Bishop captures on H7 your
queen could uh be in trouble so just
Bishop to B5 eliminating this very
strong piece uh or not if uh if nihal
captures it he can win back his Pawn
like characters captures and captures
with the queen now Queen to B6 and okay
it's nothing much black is perfectly
fine here nothing really uh happening
here so nihal says I'm not interested in
in winning back the pawn he plays Knight
to C4 which is the general idea you
wanna have access to the D6 Square
everything uh pretty much all of your
pieces are trying to make that happen
and now Knight to C6
and now comes Pawn to H4 if you go for
Knight to D6 right away it's not all
that impressive for example yes you are
threatening the B7 Pawn but Bishop
captures attacks the queen queen
captures on D3 or even Rook captures on
D3 and now B5 and the black is perfectly
fine here there is no way to take
advantage of this D file so Niha starts
the attack with H4 we have Knight to A5
Now by way so you could also capture and
just push B5 but obviously it doesn't
like this uh for example captures
captures B5 you still allow white to
keep his light Square Bishop but the
bishop is coming to B1 Queen D4 H5 is
coming could be a lot to deal with so
Wesley says okay Knight to A5 and now
Queen to E4 defending the Knight here
but also uh just threatening Checkmate
on H7 so G6 you have to play this and
now Knight to E3 now might be even a
good idea to put the Knight on D6 but
nikal abandons the plan he just
continues with Knight to E3 Knight
captures an E3 Queen captures an E3 now
threatening some very nasty discoveries
so just Queen to C7 it's finally time to
get the queen of the D file Knight to D2
the Knight now can come to E4 and then
have access to F6 which also could be
great if the Knight comes to F6 Queen
comes to H 6 you might be able to
Checkmate black so Bishop captures on D3
Queen characters and now Rook after d8
everything with Tempo not allowing
whites to mobilize the the attacking
pieces Queen to E3 and not Knight back
to C6
uh putting pressure on the E5 Pawn uh
Knights the D4 will always be an option
so Knight the E4 preparing to jump to F6
and now even though uh you sort of can't
capture an E5 it's not really a move if
you play Knight captures on E5 then uh
you will be under this pressure for for
a very long time the bishop staring at
the queen and C7 not something you want
to allow especially when you only like
Wesley said in an interview after the
first match uh he said okay it's
basically the same match but it's two
days he said that his plan is to make a
few draws and doing the match so here
Knights the D4 by Wesley and now Knight
the F6 with check with King to G7 of
course you are not interested in
capturing this so King to G7 stopping uh
the queen from coming to H6 and now
Bishop to F4 again preparing Bishop to
H6 but it's very easy to prevent this
just Knight the F5 by Wesley attacking
the queen stopping the uh Bishop H6
maneuver so Queen to H3 and now King the
h8 the distinct h8 is a very nice
tactical idea by Wesley as long as the
king is on G7 you cannot play Bishop
captures on F6 because then he captures
an F6 comes with check and then you lose
the queen and C7 by moving the king to
h8 there is no such idea and now Bishop
characters and F6 is what he is planning
so nihal cannot allow this he needs to
keep as many attackers as possible
Knight back to E4 and now Wesley starts
trading Rook captures on D1 Rook
character Sunday one and The Rook to d8
uh not night this ignite the D6 stopping
any further trades and now uh King back
to G8 you have to stop Knight captures
on F7 so King to G8 we have H5 by nihal
and now how do you defend uh there is
only one way Pawn to G5 now chases away
the bishop and the problem here is that
if you move the bishop then it's
perfectly fine to start capturing and
these six Knight captures on D6 will be
played he captures the bishop captures
you're gonna win this spawn Bishop
captures Rook captures let's say
everything gets traded off you even play
H6 you might have some ideas of Queen C3
Queen G7 Checkmate it's just a very easy
for Wesley to stop this queen D1
checking H2 Queen uh will go to D2
guarded the C3 Square now you're
attacking B to you're attacking F2 uh
it's just completely winning for black
so instead after this G5 move nihal
tries the only move that sort of keeps
him in the game and that is Pawn to H5
now saying okay if the G file opens up I
might have some very unpleasant pressure
against the black king uh but it is now
up to you to decide how Wesley can get
uh through this there is only one move
that wins the game for Wesley so feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure it out while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that yes
the bishop can indeed be captured and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is G captures and F4 that's
the good stuff and now it seems like you
should be in some trouble the knife
cover Z8 the pawn covers G7 there's just
not enough time Queen to G4 check King
to f8 now luckily the Knight on F5 is
guarding the G7 Square so the only way
to continue the attack is the capture on
F5 but then you allow a very important
Susan sug for Wesley and that of course
is Rook captures and D1 which will come
with check sonite captures on F5 now if
you can get Queen to G7 you will win the
game but Rook captures and the one with
check this forces the queen away from
the G file Queen captures on D1 and now
e captures an F5 and now Wesley is up a
full Bishop but his King is kind of in a
delicate place so can nikal take
advantage of this he plays Queen D3 goes
after the F5 Pawn yes Wesley will pick
up this Pawn but then nihal can further
activate his Queen so Queen captures on
E5 Queen to D7 now threatening Queen to
C8 check which will force Wesley to give
up the bishop so Queen to D6 stopping
this and queen to C8 with check with
Bishop to d8 blocking check and now
Queen captures an F5 Wesley eliminates
the H6 pawn and now Queen captures on C5
with check King to G7 and now Queen to
D5 attacking the bishop on d8 with Queen
to B6 defending uh and now Pawn to B4 so
now whistle is just pretty much up a
full piece with H6 uh by by Wesley and
now Queen to E5 check we have Queen to
F6 blocking check Queen to D5 and now
just B6 and he was in this position on
move 43 that nihasarin resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so by winning a game six Wesley
basically wins the match because he only
needed a point and a half out of the
four game and as the fifth game ended in
a draw he wins the sixth game that's a
point and a half which means Wesley wins
the entire thing Wesley wins the global
Chess Championship Finals wins the two
hundred thousand dollars and uh quite an
amazing performance he defeated andrekin
in the quarter finals Hikaru in the
semi-finals and now nihal sarin in the
finals uh truly an amazing performance
by Wesley so here you don't really have
a way of continuing this game you could
play a few more moves let's say Ponte A4
but once Queen G5 comes uh defends the
bishop attacks the queen you will have
to decline the trade and then let's say
Pawn to B5 uh and now well let's say
captures captures and that's pretty much
it there's no more uh no more moves for
white everything is defended which means
you're just up a full piece and
continuing this would just be well
borderline disrespectful and of course
nihal not interested in that
uh so yeah that's the game and this uh
ends the the chess.com Global Chess
Championship Finals uh breakdown hope
you guys enjoyed this very nice run by
Wesley so very nice run by nihal as well
he he had some brilliant games really uh
really played an astonishing match
against anijigiri in the semi-finals uh
took it all the way to Armageddon to win
that one I bought Wesley was uh just
just a bit too much in the finals
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh once again big
congratulations to everyone who figured
out the pause the video moment because
yes it it is capturing a piece that was
offered but sometimes that's the hardest
thing to do in chess and uh well uh uh
you know congratulations to everyone who
found it and uh a special announcement I
will uh next video I upload will be
actually a game a subscriber sent me uh
he he he sent me an email saying that uh
he sacrificed his Queen three times and
I was like okay it's probably some sort
of a weird game where the the queen
sacrifice wasn't even valid or something
because those are mostly the the emails
I get uh but this game uh was nothing
like that this game was truly a beauty
and you guys will enjoy it so stay tuned
for that
um so yeah that's the video hope you
guys enjoyed it and the little
announcement I would like to thank uh
subramanian Aaron is the best fiance
Marcus grebel Wesley the greatest and
James Chambers for a contribution to my
channel don't think we want to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day